la nouvelle doyenne de l'humanité est
française
âgée de 118 ans se rendrait est né le 11
février 1904 quel est votre secret
de oh alors
c'est le bon Dieu se rendrait est loin
d'être la seule sans terre française
mais combien sont-ils dans l'Hexagone
selon l'Insee près de 30 000 centenaires
sont recensés en France mais seul une
quarantaine ont plus de 110 ans on les
appelle les super centenaires parmi eux
une grande majorité de femmes et
quelques hommes dont le plus vieux
étendrait boîte âgé de seulement 111
rappelons que le record du monde de
longévité reste officiellement détenu
par la française Jeanne Calment morte à
l'âge de 122 ans en 1997